welcome to this video player shall
muster fly away from Armenia me and flag
at least so the news Oh probably plus
want to vary a bit the power of
variation with neither three Bishop g5
let's see we Oh interesting I didn't
know that this even exists exists that
this does even exist okay built up to a
five interesting yeah maybe I can go
even a d5 here may be an interesting
point sacrifice TX takes now maybe it
has even though a theoretical move is
playing really quickly yeah I thought
that bishops III bc 3 yeah or this this
kind of capture should give me some
compensation oh really hmm
remarkable yeah i was thinking that
somehow both before I should have
something it look so it looks a bit
strange flex position in my book ok
let's start start aggressively trying to
to punish him getting pieces out yeah at
least his covering see for this way but
I have bishop d 6 cm maybe be three then
mmm Bishop c4 is also move but then it
can maybe take a 3m
on night c4 and tending 96 yeah taking
certain deletes to a position with lots
of compensation tough to judge with very
little time I will play be three it's
also possible let me take on over this
move but there should be five isn't this
any good then you will take night a five
and queen takes each five or what a sick
variation if I take a five is going to
give the check here okay a check is a
problem in many kin many ways
okay very remarkable defensive move we
have six a plate but should be five it
takes on a three and really cute I could
actually take a five but very
questionable if this is any any serious
compensation hmm check check
Jeff master i still really cannot
believe what he's doing maybe I'm just
too optimistic a play of it to me it
looks totally wacky but okay it's got
the a pond it's got all those extra
pieces here extra points o gauge five
maybe start like that noreen g6 maybe in
Koenji seven years playing attending
Bishop g4 I all I can I can play here
it's not like this thing is promoting
immediately Bishop b5 first or bishop
page six the bishop therefore I mean
let's start like that
what a crazy position thoroughly don't
have any time I give the check here King
age 7 is going to be good Joe can also
start to hide real but it won't be
enough I guess the chick on g7 you will
take age 6 no check taking here with
chick yeah okay shall not really do it
with the time check Jenny yeah white
resigned now that was I was just a by
far too slow in this side complications
the position is certainly good for white
pretty sure about that let's see yeah of
course it is it is totally totally
bonkers I mean I have no idea what was
happening before hand but I really don't
believe in that black sir Swiss cheese
set up here with g5 and everything's
week and so on hard to believe maybe I
really need to play but should be too
and castles as the computer suggests
this is a certainty good compensation
yeah Queen f6 is really a very strong
move I guess everything else is is
really bad
okay here you can take and see if on c4
and play b3 check which is probably very
good fun check now this is good for
black probably the party Sam is keeping
my pieces at bay to route yeah it's just
dangerous i mean be a computer gives it
as equal interesting yeah i can just
take should be five is good for what
yeah yeah this first okay that's a big
difference I must provoke f6 first and
then back here interesting and this is
not not on due to queen bee three check
this is the big point I'm having the
check now yeah this is the kind of
accuracy that's very toughen and blitz
chess that's a huge difference really he
must play of six i guess i really don't
i mean this this is he I cannot believe
our roots III g3 kilts okay so f six and
then back here and then no he does not
have the counter play that's that's
quite nice for wide it's not winning
obviously the computer is not giving me
a big edge just lose something very
complicated of course you know the
guests in the game I hear Bishop f4
wince I played that you should page six
this this is losing Luke g5 swinging
okay and just taking it yeah I didn't
think of just taking it really plus five
diseases
yeah I didn't want to exchange Queens
but the problem is he's still in a
meeting net and over this is just check
made Jim I was pretty sure there should
be something but does this is losing due
to do 295 probably be sure be towards
the shot I defense but yeah I'm just I'm
just leaving the house yes was I was I
was too much down on the clock to find
it with some time maybe but I work a
here this is not exactly rocket science
but what I overlooked it really is that
he he has this problem here Musti must
take this first basically and then he's
mated it if he cannot take it I am a
rock up and the look is really too much
him this is all nice but it's a whole
look yeah very Karthik game thanks for
watching